I have for you I guess what I would call
a Maga meltdown
but it's a Maga Pastor okay
giving is a Shane Vaughn giving a speech
or a sermon or a remark whatever you
want to call it about Trump and why his
followers his viewers should support
Trump within the context of their
religion
and
what we're seeing here listen this is
not anti-christianity anti-religion at
all this is look at the way he's bending
his religion to support his cult it's
very very concerning
you are the 12 disciples
that God is called to stand behind
Donald Trump
and if Satan can get you tired
Donald Trump loses
because he cannot do this without you
and they know that
so that's why every day drama
trauma and then here's what Cal would
say I'm tired of all the drama it's not
drama it's spiritual warfare learn the
difference
carnal-minded people think it's drama
when the enemy is attacking and you are
Defending Your territory like Donald
Trump is that's not drama that is
spiritual warfare for the nation of
America it's not pretty it's not fun
it's not clean but somebody's got to do
it call me somebody
Somebody's gotta do it roar 24. I have
made up my mind I'm more determined now
than I've ever been to stand behind this
President I'm more determined now to
stand behind the anointing I don't agree
with everything the man does but I do
agree with everything that God does and
if God's okay with the man I'm ready to
join hands with every one of you I need
some proof that God's okay with Trump
sir and sing like the old black churches
used to to say I'm not tired yet
so let's just set aside that end part
um and try to understand I'm laughing
and it's kind of that you laugh so you
don't cry situation because a lot of
people are bought into this and I know
this anecdotally
um and we understand this in the amount
of people who are hardcore behind Trump
and how that intermingles with their or
intertwines with their faith and so
often when I talk to people about this
it doesn't to me seem like
and again it's your belief system of
course that's completely up to you but
it doesn't seem like you're actually
trying to drive your political beliefs
with uh with something like this uh with
your faith it seems like you really want
to love Trump and so then you're kind of
figuring out how to say well
whatever is going on I know for sure
that God loves Trump so I have to love
Trump
but don't exactly explain why God uh has
chosen Trump as the anointed one as he
said there and when I watched that I
just feel like I'm watching a
documentary about a cult about the Trump
cult you know 50 years from now how Wild
was that Trump cult it really is a
historical event at one point he said
you are the 12 disciples that God has
called to stand behind Donald Trump
yikes and so what is so concerning about
this is
in politics
it can get pretty heated and you can
disagree a lot but at the end of the day
if you're able to sit down at a table
lay the facts on the table and then
disagree about the solutions disagree
about minor things Oh I thought this was
the study that best represents the data
and I thought that is all perfectly
within a reasonable political system and
still with people agreeing on basic
facts you'll still
fall very differently on different
political views a hundred percent
what we've gotten to now is individuals
like the Shane Vaughn
make it to where
the ideology is such a circle and it is
such uh you know an impossible situation
to get pulled out of that we can't sit
down and talk about facts I can't even
sit down and try to explain to you why I
think Trump might be against the Bible
because you can Trump that all no pun
intended by saying it doesn't matter I
know for sure that God has anointed
Trump and so it really makes it deeply
impossible
to get somebody out of that cult and
that is what is so concerning about this
and it's why we have to continue to talk
about it and raise awareness and
hopefully
by some miracle well some people out of
it but I can tell you one thing it's not
going to be sir Pastor Shane Vaughn
thank you all for watching Today's show
if you enjoyed me hosting go over to
Luke Beasley
on YouTube check out my show the Luke
Beasley show and make sure you're
subscribed there and to the David Pacman
show here on YouTube we will see you
soon